all of these personal experiences don't
involve you
speaking
don't involve you
in any way having to be an extrovert hi
there steve kaufman here again to talk
about language learning and today i want
to talk about language learning
and the introvert or people who are
introverted
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
if you follow me on a podcast service oh
yes and by the way click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a review
so
my last or one of my most recent
interviews was
a discussion with gabriel from brazil i
have spoken to other people about
language learning
in different languages and i would think
that
many of the people who show up on
youtube as polyglots or talk about
language learning including myself
are probably
extroverts in other words i'm not shy if
i go to a party and i see people i want
to talk
and interact with people and i'm not shy
about
sharing my views on different subjects
and so forth so i am an extrovert i
think gabriel is an extrovert someone
commented that you know it seems
saying to me you always have extroverts
on there talking about language learning
what about introverts who want to learn
languages so i thought i would talk a
bit about that
i don't think being an extrovert is a
condition
for being a polyglot or a linguist
remember that if you look up
the word linguist in an english language
dictionary the first meaning is someone
who speaks several languages
the second meaning one that has
developed much later in history is this
idea of someone who studies linguistics
the word polyglot just means many
tongues or many languages
so
if you are a person who is interested in
languages
because you like to read in different
languages which is my case
and you like to discover different
languages
and you enjoy this very personal
experience of let's say reading in
different languages or even listening in
different languages
on subjects of interest to you
listening to voices that you like
enjoying the sound of different
languages all of these personal
experiences
don't involve you
speaking
don't involve you
in any way having to be an extrovert
being
outgoing
hail fellow well-met or any of these
things
so you can be a wonderful
polyglot
linguist
language learner
and decide to totally focus on input
only now
i think the majority of people who focus
on input at some stage want to speak
it's normal for people to want to speak
but even the desire to speak doesn't
mean that you're always looking for an
opportunity to speak that you're sort of
naturally bursting to say things which
is sort of the
uh characteristics that we associate
with an extrovert you can be somewhat
introverted that doesn't mean you're not
a deep thinker but you don't necessarily
want to share those thoughts with other
people all the time that's more in it's
sort of along the lines of an introvert
you don't have to speak to demonstrate
that you are learning the language you
don't have to demonstrate your prowess
or your your level of fluency in
speaking in order to qualify as a
polyglot in my view
now if you want to say i speak a
language fluently then you have to
demonstrate that you speak that language
fluently if you're claiming to speak it
fluently and and remember i feel you can
be fluent and still make mistakes but at
least you can express your opinions
comfortably in a way that makes the
other person feel comfortable but a big
part obviously of
being fluent is that you understand what
the other person is saying so even there
it does start with this basically
inward oriented process of learning
languages but you don't have to speak
and i've mentioned before
uh
maybe 50 years ago i was in europe in a
in a bar somewhere and there was a a
person a student from japan who could
communicate in 13 languages but he was
deaf mute i don't know what the
politically correct term is today but he
couldn't make sounds
but we would write questions to him in
13 languages and he would answer those
questions in those 13 languages he
wasn't an introvert because he he was
quite comfortable
uh you know fielding these questions and
answering them but he wasn't speaking
so he was communicating in writing so i
just want to make the point that and and
it's by no means certain you know i
think we've all seen that say in a class
the person who's sort of bubbling and uh
willing to try things and then it's it's
a good thing actually to not be afraid
of making mistakes
and so that person seems to speak better
earlier
again that doesn't mean that in the long
run that person will have a better
understanding of the language be able to
read better in the language than someone
who doesn't speak very much but is more
focused on
input but more focused on discovering
the language reading in the language so
i guess the only part i want to make and
this is in answer
to the question that i received
you know why don't you ever talk about
introverts who learn languages yes by
all means
language learning is a personal
experience activity we do it for
ourselves we do it
in the way that that makes us happy that
satisfies us that satisfies our
curiosity our interests our personality
and whatever degree of
and i'm and because it's not black and
white people are all introverts or all
extroverts there's a degree and given
certain situations some people are more
inclined to be
bubbling outgoing personalities and
others less so wherever you are on the
spectrum it has nothing to do
with a person's ability to be a polyglot
or a language learner or a linguist in
my opinion
and so i'm going to leave a couple of
videos suggestions here if you want to
pursue this subject in some of the
videos that i've already made thank you
for listening bye for now